is this too often st. John how's the
talks going for Dino charge coming for
Power Rangers Dino charge series talks
for Dino charge yeah well as of right
now they've been going on for about a
couple of seconds no actually I've
spoken with the executive producers for
the company once I got back from the
Middle East
chip is one of the current executive
producers and I was in the Middle East
over the last four years working as a
medic and I met with chip in Pasadena
and he explained to me that they spent
the last couple of seasons where I was
not available I was in the Middle East
bringing back some of the original
Rangers so I kind of missed that boat he
says but now that we know that you're
back you know we'll have to see what the
future holds we don't I think he doesn't
see anything coming in the next couple
of seasons but he was excited to hear
from me I was excited to talk to him and
we'll see what happens
so no contracts no promises but you
never know when to be exciting to see
the Red Ranger backyard and should I
shave everybody's like you need to shave
like I kind of all right she's like no
she don't shave ma'am I'll be the
bearded Ranger yeah not the bearded lady
the bearded Ranger let's keep that
stranger
you